hi there today we're trying something
different something new we're
broadcasting on youtube but we're
listening to you on LinkedIn why because
the vice president of the European
Commission now a chef Javitch is here
with us in the studio in order to
crowdsource your best suggestions on how
the EU can trigger more innovation
especially in the field of clean tech
the best ideas will be presented
tomorrow by the vice president at the
clean energy Industrial Forum which
we'll talk about in a minute
so if you would like to pitch your
suggestions please visit the LinkedIn
page of vice president mal Shaff Javitch
and add your ideas in the comments under
this video we'll go over them as many as
we can during this broadcast and try to
discuss them here in the studio we
received quite a lot over the past few
days and will try to bring those as well
before we start the conversation let me
also introduce the three panelists and
guests that we have here in our studio
the first one is Professor Damian Delton
from Ireland you're the CEO of beyond
next to you is Emma wok slim from Sweden
you're the co-founder of epicene and
next to me who I Halle from Slovakia
co-founder and managing partner of volt
here so the way it's going to work is
that we're going to try to a crowdsource
as I just said the best ideas that come
from our LinkedIn community but you will
get a chance also to try to suggest to
the vice-president what you would do if
you were in his position but let me
start with you ice president thank you
for being here with us I have a
confession to make risk watching your
LinkedIn page right now because we're
broadcasting from there because you have
a community of three hundred and forty
thousand followers we thought it would
be an interesting place to start to
transmit this conversation from but I'd
like to ask you about the timing that
we're having this conversation I'd like
to ask you about this forum why is it so
important for you and what are you
hoping to get out of this exercise what
kind of ideas will be useful for you and
how would you use them No thank you very
much Annette first I would like to thank
our guests that are ready to talk about
this very important topic with us and I
hope that the LinkedIn community will
also bring some of innovative ideas
because I I'm on that page very often
and I see that I get a lot of very good
suggestions from the LinkedIn community
so why today and why on this topic
tomorrow we are actually launching our
first edition on the of the clean energy
industrial forum because it was quite
obvious that if you
want to remain leader in the clean tech
in renewables technology we have to get
our business leaders together with the
mayors which will happen for the first
time tomorrow's with the policymakers
and really to share what they believe we
should do together as a Europeans and I
am travelling across the globe a lot and
I'm always impressed what we have in
Europe in our labs what kind of
innovation and ecosystems we can build
what we have in our universities and I'm
glad to be here Sacheon co-founder a
very innovative company with us and
therefore I think that we have to
showcase more we have to network more
and we have to find the recipes how to
get these great ideas from the
Innovation Lab into the practice and
really to use and build the technology
here not in Silicon Valley or somewhere
else but here in Europe and therefore
I'm very glad that we can have this
chance to crowdsource the best ideas how
it can accomplish that in Europe okay so
before you take the floor and you make
the suggestions let us learn a little
bit about who you are and where you came
from
Damian you're from Ireland maybe you can
tell us a little bit but who you are and
what is beyond your company okay thanks
very much
bianna is a company that's working in
the data center energy management field
believe it or not it didn't disappoint
the fact that the Dynamo of the cloud
are great when in terms of CTR for
servers and communications but when it
comes to energy management they're
really very inefficient so our
technology enables you to analyze your
data center in terms of physical
attributes such as kilowatts but also in
terms of Business Objects and identify
energy-saving actions so that you can
cut down your capex and OPEX cost by
maybe 30% and that also impacts your
environmental impact
so exactly okay Emma I will not ask you
how old you are I would never ask a lady
but how old were you when you started
because something in my math doesn't
make sense and I feel like I didn't do
anything in my life when I look at
someone like you who is a co-founder we
started working nine to three years ago
when I was 24 at the time yes okay
that's quite impressive the researchers
started to work and innovation behind
fbtime before I was born
okay so way so the research started
before but you co-founded this company
so what is the P shine we're developing
a new kind of solar cell and with new
materials and a new way of manufacturing
them so we have been focusing on
excluding all toxic and rare materials
from the solar cells so they're made
only from organic materials they look
like this
and we also developed extremely simple
and extremely scalable manufacturing
process to print them okay sounds good
and your last but not least on my right
tell us about volt here yeah actually I
started personally as a banker and after
10 years working in a bank
I switched you to become an interpreter
so I that was really a big challenge we
started with the photovoltaic industry
back to 2008 really eat that was good
time for for that for uptake and so on
and back to 2011 we started to companies
to and other startups in immobility
one of those is voltea second one is
Greenway both doing very well and
speeding up the pace what is what you
are doing we are helping to switch to
electric a double eat or even personal
customers we help to integrate
electric vehicles into the normal
business life of the companies so if you
allow me to simplify we have energy
efficiency we have renewables we have
electricity yeah immobility do you want
to start maybe with pitching your first
idea policy idea to the vice president
who wants to go first maybe we'll start
where am i if you're ready I can start
with a challenging one maybe and I would
like to you to help us enter into the
large corporations in Sweden and some of
them still have not invented here
mindset and one way I was thinking you
can do this it's like for example when
the big car companies for and
when it comes to doing every six
regulations you give them panels tastes
like money penalties and even prison
which will not really help the
environment and so my tradition is that
you could instead give them like a list
of startups or SMEs
working with innovations or solution
that could help them meet the
regulations and like demand them to
cooperate and work with us yeah if you
want to yeah I can I thank you very much
for for that ideas because I think
especially on that suggestion who can
help them or bring the innovation to the
big companies it's actually the very
good idea which I also heard yesterday
when we've been preparing for our
batteries meeting on Friday that how to
make this matchmaking between those who
are ready to invest in production line
of the batteries and where they would
have a demand with the car manufactures
with the construction industry be
interesting how much of the batteries
they they would need so they've been
asking for some kind of matchmaking
platform and this is probably another
idea where we have to think how to
really make sure that these good ideas
are not lost they're not traveling
across across the ocean but they're
proposed to the European companies who
would have them better information what
is available here in Europe and how to
get in touch with you and second idea
what do you what do you suggest it is
true that we in Europe have a big
problem to move the product from the
from the innovation up into the market
and what I hear from the innovative
community that this is from this these
loans are financing between two to five
million to get you through so-called
death valley - to make it to actually
scaling up the production and we are
thinking now how we can adjust our
financial instruments so that would be
much more simpler for use because I know
that very often our innovators are
scared to go through all the
administrative process because it's very
very very cumbersome so I fully
understand your point and we all try to
think how we can use that great idea
gentlemen if you allow me before I let
you pitch I want to also bring on board
our online audience so I have my first
question from available veg
works for solar power Europe so when
we're unlinked and we know a little bit
about who's saying what and he's she
says it's very important to build a
stable industrial pipeline to encourage
innovation and scanning up of our
technologies which is basically the
broad question that we have here today
but what I found interesting in many of
the comments that we got is that many of
them the EU is already doing and I don't
know if ice president you want to react
on some of these existing platforms that
that exist what is out there so that
when people ask what is the EU proposing
to for the EU to do more maybe you can
tell them what already exists before we
because I think that if it comes to the
to the solar industry there's been
several challenges over the last years
the first one is that that we came up
with is innovation will be started and
then somehow due to different factors we
kind of lost that production capacity
and now we are importing most of our
panels from China so I hope that Emma
with her company a little bit will be
will be very successful and that we will
bring something new to the quality of
solar panels and I hope the same for the
batteries that we would be able to
demonstrate to the European customers
but also worldwide that what we are
aiming at is actually higher quality of
solar panels higher quality of batteries
let's call them green panels green
batteries where we would have much
stronger standardization where we would
be very careful about sustainability
about transparency from what we are
getting for example the the the raw
materials and how much we are thinking
from the moment where we are designing
the products about recycling about
recollection of the of the used material
and and about potential reuse of most of
the raw materials which are used for
this for this product so so this is
something I think what we have to
achieve and where we can clearly
distinguish European quality and
European approach to sustainability to
the to the products we are importing
from abroad and and second challenge
solar industry was facing in the past
was that because of some retroactive
changes they really lost what is so
important for investing into the new
technologies and this is in
a certainty investor stability and
therefore we introduce in our new laws
which would guide us through this very
important energy transformation special
clothes on if I simplified and I've got
non-retroactivity that once you are
investing let's say in solar power and
once the contract I signed that they
cannot be retro actively changed because
in that case very difficult to get our
investors into this new technology so
these are a few things which I would
mention at this stage because we need to
make sure that the innovators would see
the Europe is the primary target market
maybe to go back to what already was
saying about how we can help the scaling
up one of the interesting platforms that
the EU was involved in is the knowledge
and innovation communities the kicks so
I know that Damian you've had experience
in inner energy and ma you've been in
kick a climate kick sorry I think that
more or less goes in line of the
question of how we can actually help but
maybe you can tell us about your
experience well energy is concerned with
three three strands this innovation
business creation and education although
all those that's what's really important
when you want bring new technologies to
them to the market and where we were in
Ireland we know we have a great
enterprise broad there we have a lot of
data centers and do you think with a
solution that can save you 30% energy
you think this is a no-brainer we just
go ahead and set it now
the unfortunate thing about from our
point of view about the dead
centenarians is that like Google they're
a Facebook they're all highly efficient
they don't reflect the average type of
data center so when we talk to them
initially they weren't really interested
and our is no on the western seaboard
although we have a lot of high tech
companies we don't really have exposure
maybe to a broader market I mean that's
when the problem for startups you know
you need to have a value proposition for
a customer so how did Kate come in and
help you so what kick did for us was
they they're in we we got to the
Eindhoven branch and they expose us
really to the whole of Europe so just
what is kick so this this
knowledge and innovation community well
the European project is in sustainable
there's a largest sustainable energy
project in Europe and from our point of
view they invested in our company in
terms of cash and also in terms of
development the the concept the ideas
and training and they also have an
annual showcase which may be in the
location like Barcelona or Amsterdam
that brings together all the companies
and all the various stakeholders who
have an interest in your technology so
it means you're not just talking to a
local or a national level of potential
clients or customers you're talking to
Europe and that's what we really need is
we want to talk to Europe I think most
countries center up locally or
nationally when they're going through
their enterprise boards that's
understandable but really I think you
need to introduce companies into a
broader field and that's what energy
does it brings me to a broader complete
concretely how has it influenced your
business well first of us give us
clarity about what we need to do the
value proposition the client so for
instance we were talking to data center
managers dead center managers are
mandated just to deliver continuity and
security but we have to move up into the
sea level chain to the guys who have
paying for the bills
there's only through exposure through
communication with the market on a broad
sense we were able to ascertain that
that really is for our market is it's
not at the lowest level in the
hierarchies of the top level and there
that's where the decision is made for
products like us
so it caters and really about what the
markets about so if you had to advise or
to suggest to the vice-president you
would say that this is something that
it's worked well for you
we'd like to present them to the
innovators community as EU incubators
and I'm glad that I mean in your case it
works and you know energy is one of the
the most successful one because I have
very positive positive feedback on what
they what they do and hopefully more and
more innovators will be linked with them
and you can you know have the same
successful stories as you do yeah I
think you would like the next question
that or suggesting that we have here
does anybody speak Spanish because it's
Jose Qantas I think he is from Barcelona
I'm not
Sakthi sure how to pronounce his name is
an automotive software engineer and is
suggesting that we draw competitions
aimed at inviting companies to overcome
certain thresholds or challenges and the
reason I thought you would like it is
because I happen to know that you're a
finalist in an EU starter prize that is
going to take place tomorrow so once
again it's a suggestion that I think I
personally like I hope the
vice-president does as well but I think
there are quite a few of them but maybe
you can tell us about the one that you
are participating in yeah I'm very happy
that we've been selected out of I think
few hundreds of companies and tomorrow
we'll find around where 10 companies
will present I mean what they can bring
it's it's it's really good that for even
smaller startups in our case we live
already seven eight years so it's we are
not that small kind of scalable and so
on but it's it's as it was mentioned
valuable that it's hard to survive first
three years we all know I mean after the
first three years 90% of the companies
will just or starter will just die so
the first thing is I mean you have to be
alive and and then you can I mean speed
up the pace so the first thing is I mean
to be there so we are really happy I'm
also really happy that the e-mobility
which we are I'm here as a
representative immobility that is taking
the pace I can tell you back to 2011 we
were one of the first companies when we
started even in the Central East Europe
everybody was looking at us come on guys
why do you do mean it really true that
that you want to do something with the
immobility world so imagine that time
first test laws well came to Europe and
so on so that was the time so I'm really
happy that the the the immobility is
already taking the pace and there is a
lot of things which we have to do here
in this place and I have a young one I
think quite good suggestion what to do
hopefully let's see when we started back
to 2008 there was a there started a lot
of subsidies for the solar industry
I was represented that at that time the
industry and it was really good and I
remember
first it just helps the industry to grow
but right after all these retro active
things came and policies came into place
and that was the reason what was just
because some of the states they were
they just thought that it's maybe too
much that the feed-in tariff was too
high and so on and just like shaping
maybe wrong direction the industry as
such so so that's why there's this kind
of takes so maybe to avoid such a
situation when we talk about immobility
would be very wise and what we were
thinking that instead of granting let's
say let the general lump sum subsidies
let's say to the evey owners what if we
switch the model for something like
pay-as-you-go something like to evey
users so what if somebody who is really
heavily using electric vehicles
well because he's the one who saves the
emissions whatsoever and of course he
should be also rewarded for that rather
than somebody who is owning a car
sitting somewhere garage so that's
Dahlia is quite simple why not to
support those users instead of I mean
holders of the Eevee's that's first one
for for now maybe respond to to Jose I
think that finally in in Europe we also
embrace that concept of this award
inducement prizes I'm very glad that
arrival participates more of in in the
final and good luck and I think it's on
Friday we also going to launch another
award we should be done by my colleague
responsible for innovation Carlos motors
where for the first time we are going to
have to announce that the prize for best
greenest cleanest battery and it's quite
valued one because it's 10 million euros
in it so we just want to motivate the
innovative teams around the Europe to
enter into this competition and so now
help us not only to catch up the
competition from from the AGI but
already to work on the next for the
fifth generation of the batteries
which would have all this I would say
European characteristic and I hope that
would be a motivation for for the
innovation teams across the Europe and
on the on the subsidies I think of you
rise right that we we have to be clear
very clever how to do that because in in
actually the solar industry at that time
I remember very well that Member States
very much wants to use the subsidiarity
rule and they wanted to decide it
everything by themselves so some
countries really I mean the feeling
there have been over shots then during
the economic crises they they found that
they cannot you know continue the
support because of the financial burden
and it caused a lot of damage to the
industry so here I think we we have to
think twice how to do it if we want to
have each third card on our roads by
2030 which would have electric element
means it will be zero emission or all
mission meaning hybrid car and and how
to do it at the same time that it would
be like technically not challenging and
and that it would be user-friendly and
something for which we can convince the
Member State it's good idea to implement
and meanwhile for for this question it's
not only the Eurovision there are other
tech competitions in Europe that there
are maybe less popular and well-known
but they are happening around I'm moving
from Jose from Spain to Marco's LAN
Keenan from Finland who also sent us an
interesting proposal and he's talking
about cities vice-president I know that
it's a topic that you have a passion for
how the EU can work with the local level
and how they can lead the energy
transition forward he doesn't go into
very specific details on how he thinks
that that we should do it but I don't
know if you can tell us maybe on all our
our partners in this discussion I I
think and sure they experience how they
projects actually contributing to
smartening the cities because this is
again something where I think Europe is
leading the world and therefore we very
much support the concept of the smart
cities and when we look what the smart
city actually is it first of course you
have to be very sustainable in how we
run the cities we want to have the
intelligence organization of the of the
transport and to take care of air
pollution of traffic germs which are the
major headaches for every mayors and
then we also are supporting the
technologies which allow about surveys
management better better water
management and and also making sure that
the industry in the cities is
contributing to the to the quality of
life for the for the local population so
this is I would say the areas where we
know to help with our new budget with
our structural funds but exactly the
projects like it was mentioned here that
very efficient data centers who can
share the heat and consume less cooling
material less water or the the solar
panels which would be very modern and
were the administrative buildings or the
family households wouldn't hesitate and
they will put put it on on on the roof
and use it or for electric vehicle or
for for for batteries to store the
energy they can they can they can use
later so all this is happening and
therefore we know that mayors are
actually very much at the forefront how
to embrace these new technologies
because the people are complaining first
to them if there is a traffic jam if
there is a air pollution so the mayors
are first addresses and therefore
tomorrow what we did was actually we put
together and that you covenant of mayors
we have more than 6000 mayors just only
from Europe and seven and a half
thousand mayors from all around the
world to work on the sustainability
agenda they will be here tomorrow they
will present how they want to make the
cities smarter because each of them had
to develop the sustainability plan and
then we are going to bring them together
with the industrial and innovative
community just to share the thoughts
this is what we need this is what you
can offer how can we make this happen
and how can we make the the cities maybe
the major customers of these new
innovative technologies so the role of
Europe would basically to bring bring
them together the financial institutions
the cities and in the technology we are
also providing a lot of financing for
the cities we just approved
a few days ago a new instrument is
called smart finance for smart cities
where we want to bring additional 10
billion euros between now and 2020 for
energy efficiency in in our city so
everything which falls under that
umbrella efficient data center solar
panels on the roof or the immobility
solution for the cities falls under and
that financing instrument and what I
hear from the different green bankers in
Europe pension funds and so on they are
ready to invest and financed but they
need good projects so that would be also
the message to the mayors and project
promoters tomorrow if you have a good
project we have mechanism how to help
you through the EIB through national
promotional banks through investment
platforms to to get it financed we have
a suggestion exactly on that we have
Ralph Becker from the Netherlands well
who are telling us that it seems that
banks and multinationals are still very
conservative so he's saying it's not
only about finding the finance it's also
convincing them that this new way of
doing business is you know they don't
necessarily buy in I don't know if you
have had experience of how it is to
convince the old-school bankers to
believe and convey to them the spark in
your eyes that this is actually the next
next best thing I mean isn't has it been
so difficult yep I can tell you so I was
one of those I was the banker and after
that was the case that time years ago
when we started with the solar industry
yeah it's true and I think the times are
I mean getting better but still you have
to have a real good business case and
you have to have it's the pitch is just
one thing and but you cannot persuade I
mean without the numbers without the
budget without a plan and without real
let's say that the content the marketing
is really good stuff around it but the
content should be really good and you
have to also understand what what the
bankers are expecting from you if if you
want to I mean have a loan which is
let's say 10 times bigger than what
your assets so I mean I can understand
that forward typical I mean for the
banker that's a problem but on the other
hand we know and we hear it more and
more often that that because of the low
let's say margins now in the banks they
they are pushed to do come up with the
new projects because they understand the
some of some where there might be a new
Google might be new that's a microscope
or whoever even Apple so they on one
hand they laugh to invest in such
companies in later stage this is
typically the case in a very early stage
typically that's the case that somebody
has to help so typically first stage
friends-and-family stage then you go
after you have something angel investor
then maybe the family you might be in
trouble
bankers really for early stage into your
post revenue going to a bank that
certainly knows the experiences they
just what don't want to know pretty
wings just IEP there's no security what
in my case you have to go personally so
you know as a security or guarantor for
the loan and this is one of the issues
like how do you get your product forward
I mean Peter Thiel who is one of the you
know greatest serial entrepreneurs in
Silicon Valley you know he's on being a
made project leader musk he said that
most innovative technologies are the
ones in which the inventor or the
entrepreneur has a secret that no one
else acknowledges so this like Reiner
was the first Irish company that said
you could have budget travel everyone
else said he it's impossible have a
budget travel you know Elon Musk said
she could have reusable rockets you know
last week so when you're on entrepreneur
and when you're really innovative you
need to develop case studies you need to
prove your technology and that's very
difficult to do first of all people
don't believe you haven't got time to
know to deal with prototypes so you
that's the only way you go forward to
prove the technology and that's where I
think the EU can come in I said through
networking so that you're not just
looking at your national local
environment for a client or a customer
who needs your solution the solutions
going out and is rather like in a sea of
ideas and opportunities
floating around there maybe the solution
is over in France not in Ireland you
know the someone's looking for your
problem so we need to disseminate your
problem through a port or maybe an
online portal that's European so that
others can see the opportunity that's
there and take it on board and try to
become the early adopters once you've
gotten really doctor then you can take
to the next stage so really that is
really I think the value of death for a
lot of startups great ideas but just
trying to find where the customer is
whereas the value proposition once
you've done that then you can go to the
next stage and maybe to add to this I
think we in this commission we started
with the new instrument which was and
exactly that the risking this initial
investment and the name of the inquiry
investment fund because what we clearly
felt when we started three years ago was
that Europe is heavily under invested
and they still were investment levels
been in the pre-crisis levels and just
to restart a normal investment cultures
we decided to create this risking fund
which we are managing through the the
EIB which Marla says if you invest in
this project in this technology first
eventual losses are upon us
and it and it open I was a lot of
opportunity so far we reinvested through
this one two hundred sixty billion euros
so it's a lot of money that was quite a
big success in of the first three years
so we decided to have a half a trillion
fund until until 2020 so there is this
possibility but I think it would be very
interesting to hear also from from our
audience from the LinkedIn who tried it
was that personal experience with it
because a lot of projects has been
founded like this but to be quite honest
most of them in infrastructure a lot of
them in energy efficiency and all that
quite a few of them in in the innovation
and this is exactly the segment with
which we would like to enlarge it will
be easier for the startup community it
would be easier for the smaller
innovators to get the riskier funding
through this de-risking instruments
because I
understand also the bankers they would
like to have some backup if something
goes wrong yeah if you're watching us
and if you've had any experience of that
kind and you want to leave us a comment
we'll be very happy in many it's maybe
it's an opportunity also to if you're
joining us now to remind you we're
broadcasting live we have the vice
president of the European Commission
embellish after which and we start to
piste and we are collecting your ideas
on what the EU can do more on top to
promote clean tech in Europe from what
we've gathered in discuss so far I think
that part of this exercises may be to
let the people or your community or
LinkedIn know that so much is happening
already because I have a feeling that
many of the proposals the answer is but
we are but I think there have been a few
already and maybe we will summarize in a
few in a few minutes but I wanted to
there's a interesting question that
actually came or suggestion in the house
from an employee of the Commission named
the margherita Gaza and she says that
she knows that you've been to some of
the intensive coal regions and that
she's she's curious what was the
reaction there to this kind of rhetoric
this kind of narrative that we're
discussing here is it the younger the
older people who were more sensitive to
this topic how does it resonate with
them because we are discussing here
among entrepreneurs politicians but how
does it trickle to some of the regions
that are you know on the other side of
this transition I think such a I would
say strongest emotion I felt when I was
in Silesia which is very strong mining
region in Poland and I went to present
this idea that we from the European
level together with the national and
local levels should try to develop new
business models new economic future for
the regions which go through this very
difficult transition and of course the
the coal miners are very proud people so
I was not sure what kind of reaction I
will receive and I was presenting this
and the result was that the speaker of
the regional Parliament told me yes we
want to work with you because I'm afraid
that the younger people will continue to
leave my cities that they would like to
live in this region because they're
afraid that they will not get a good job
that the kids what suffer from
respiratory
diseases and that simply this beautiful
region of ours will not have the
economic future so work with us let's
look for the new opportunities let's
work on the new platforms and let's give
also this coal mining community new
economic future new business opportunity
this is exactly what we are trying to do
so I have to say that also the mindset
is shifting because especially the young
generation the Millennials are extremely
sensitive about the environment about
air pollution about the future of our
planet and I think also the the local
politicians feel it and we have to
combine this enthusiasm of the
Millennials with the responsibility for
social consequences of this
transformation to make sure that the
transition is fair that we would not
leave anybody behind and it would offer
new solutions and and and we have them
we have the technology we have the funds
which is need to have the the common
approach how to solve this very
sensitive format if you're watching us I
think the vice-president and optimistic
to me I think we can there's a hopeful
future and that actually connects very
well with the next question that came up
which I also like from Victoria Duma
he's a consultant in Singapore it is
sustainable and economic development
collaboratory but she's worked I looked
at her profile in Scotland in Slovakia
so I'm not exactly sure tell us where
you're from it sounds the my colleagues
tell me that your name is Hungarian and
she's asking and how do we reach
behavioural change among consumers so
you just spoke about it among
Millennials I don't know if you want to
talk you come from Sweden and you're a
millennial I mean how to change the
behavior of customers among your friends
who are not entrepreneurs at the age of
five they're preoccupied with do they
wake up in the morning and ask
themselves how can we especially when it
comes to food and a lot of them are
questioning our ways of eating meat and
most of them buy ecological even though
it's more expensive and everyone wants
to buy my soul ourselves
but there I would say they were thinking
about it on a day-to-day basis most of
them I'm not sure if they would change
some of their behaviors though Swedish
thing or a generational thing
I mean my friends in the US are my
friends in the rest of Europe same so I
think that in this case I mean two words
come to mind and first is monetization
and second is Karina fication that's a
word I learned from talking to
Millennials and I mean and I will use
the example of former Minister of
Environment ségolène royal from France
because she was very much assisting that
the social housing should be energy
efficient and they tested the different
technologies and one of the technology
was that in these apartments so there
was a screen there for screen if ocation
which said how much you pay for the use
of energy for cooking heating but what
was especially telling in the case of
millennial for long showers and then mom
could tell you know we've been there for
45 minutes it costs you 25 euros or
something similar and that somehow was
changing so that's a little bit that
people like to see that when they behave
that how much energy they save how it is
translated into the money and there are
even some kind of competitions within
the communities among the among the
houses but you need to be able to
measure it to have a smart technology to
show it on the screen and that actually
brings a new behavior of president
before you went to the one planet summit
in Paris we had the Millennials here in
the studio and they pitched ideas to you
how to involve youth and I remember that
one of the interesting ideas was to
develop an app that the Millennials
could actually look every day how much
you know how much co2 emissions I
generated I think many of us would be
afraid to see that but yeah there seems
to be demand and this idea is kind of
recurrent now yeah we would be surprised
I think
your serial entrepreneurs if you ever
want to come up with an app and the
thing that's one thing that when you're
a start-up we do tend to think of a
brand you tend to think of a just a
problem and the solution and we were in
that you know unfortunate we're in that
category and we were talking to
companies and then we realized that
because of Millennials people are you
know companies are more aware that they
have to be corporate social responsible
and have a green agenda so it's not a
case they just have to do business have
to be seen that they're doing something
about the environment so we were right
to tag on to that instead of the same
weeks we do energy management
performance management we've actually
built a campaign around that concept and
so when companies buy on technology now
they can go onto a website and show what
carbon they're they're saving and this
is to the public so it could there's two
things for us it shows our technology
works if it also shows that they're
doing something about it they're buying
into the agenda so I think startups you
know usually tend to postpone branding
to the end and think about whatever
brand we are we were in that category
but if you take it early on and look at
it in the bigger context you bring in
the Millennials bringing in a wider
population who can see that your brand
is part of the sustainability agenda in
Europe and we've worked on that and we
even have a campaign that we've been
disabled a million tons in Europe your
perspective is entrepreneurs but to go
back maybe to the purpose of the
exercise what would you expect the EU to
do in order to to create this kind of
change of mindset I mean from what I
hear from what you're saying this is
happening anyway but if you were the
vice president to think in a more
sustainable way I think you have to show
that it first of all you have to get the
educate you have to tell people and not
tell people that's wrong what to say I
think you have to highlight the benefits
and the success stories that through
case studies and show that it's not just
the you know the business that is
gaining we our society and gaining on a
number of fronts environmental economic
social all those aspects and communicate
with the community and the community is
you know your your business space it's
not just the you know the end customer
it's a wider space than that so I think
that has to be done in a number of ways
through you know constant through social
networking through publications
generally speaking use old facilities
that we now have in the modern era to
highlight what can be achieved and what
is being achieved okay
there's an interesting suggestion that I
would think would interest the to a
Slavic Slovaks around the table not
because you're Slovaks but you
understand in a moment some welly let's
say any everything sounds better in
Italian I don't know why he's from the
Italian Authority for energy networks
and environment and he's suggesting he
is very sensitive to the question of
electrification of transport and heating
and he says why aren't there
EU standards across these kind of
technologies particularly given as an
example plugs for electric vehicles so
that cars can drive across Europe and
use the same plug to charge so yeah
there I think it's true that when you
start with something new like the ECAR
so you have different competing
technologies but now I think if it comes
to the plug so the EU standards is
already agreed it's so-called type 2
plug which should be really used as the
EU standard all across the Europe so
there will be smooth driving across the
EU at the same time I have to say that
we have also cars like Tesla day they
prefer still to have they their own
charging system so but we are working on
on that as well that that type 2 would
be perceived as a european standard and
at the same time what i think it's very
important for this particular segment of
the business is that we need something
like the roaming of charging so we
recall the charging yes we call it we
actually call it a roaming meaning that
because if and i'm sure that you can
explain it better than I do so if you
want to charge the car today so you have
to have a card which you use for
charging your card so what I think we
have to achieve is that it's when you
cross the borders and go to in other
countries who can use the same car then
you can you can you can charge your your
car and we also need the the intelligent
charging stations meaning that any look
at your navigation they would get that
if
where is the closest charging station of
course in in your country but also I
mean our our people would like to drive
all across the Europe so I think we need
this compatibility not only on plugs but
also on this on discharging cars and
also on the signal this charging station
would send out so anyone who needs
charging would easily find them yeah
so some well it's being taken care of
don't worry not yet but we are working
on we just need eight hundred thousand
stations charging stations across the
Europe we have two hundred thousand of
them so from every movement in Europe to
free movement in here so you can go
wherever you want with your electric car
you don't know what is your experience
with yeah that's true I mean it's it's
much more than that in China they have a
different standard and us a different
standard Tesla has different standard
and of course the first understanding
which came from Japan is still part of
the Europe because of the friends aliens
and so on and of course we know that the
type 2 will be the case for EU so I mean
the direction is kind of given but still
take the example of the cell phones so
if you have a Samsung Apple and so on so
there is a lot of I mean you have to
have your own cable otherwise sometimes
correctly there are already standardized
European Center nights for charger USB
yes but not for the other part of the
cable and that's actually the thing also
with the electric cars so I think this
is one thing the other thing what was
mentioned regarding regarding the
roaming I think that's something imagine
the situation again from the telecom
industry today I was flying and the
operators were changing in my phone
automatically so the future of the
traveling with with the e car is that
you will have one card and the operators
will allow you to charge wherever you go
with one course that's that's already I
mean standard which is which is for
phones to revolution it works
yeah I think already honor let's a
national level you can do like that and
we as I mentioned three start up one of
those is the Greenway the company which
we are running in a central Eastern
Europe doing actually this this part of
the job and yes we have a customers
which they go abroad and they use their
card and yeah it's it's evolving and
that's I mean given direction okay we're
nearing the end so I'd like to ask each
of you if you want to add still
something and last suggestion that you
have not had the chance to bring to the
vice president before I asked the vice
president to kind of conclude the main
ideas that he collected from from today
maybe yeah if you wish to say you know
the what we have in Europe in terms of
programs it really is no extensive and
that's very one the aspects that's its
downsize there's so many opportunities
so many programs for a start-up is hard
to navigate through all of them so
there's a simplification how you can get
into the system things are also really
good meaning as you be an example of
this is that the incubation period for
projects that are proposed to funding
can be very short sometimes can be very
long are for instance horizon 2020 we
went into to horizon 2008 II programs
and took 18 months between submission
and finally getting as rejection for
starts of this is really too long you
may not be around for the rejection so I
think having a I think having a shorter
assessment period like inner energy was
only three months so we went through
through to stringent processes in terms
of the company I'm the technology and we
got a decision pretty quick and that was
really to our advantage and we just
basically sido and so keep things short
sharp and just keep doing what the
Commission is doing already and bring
all those ideas in because there's some
great ideas out there and we want to see
the money and for you it's even more
critical yeah yeah so there's great
ideas out there talk to our students in
new CD you know just coach mm loads them
have great sustainable ideas some of
them sure will come into the into the
arena in years to come they just want to
know how to get into the programs and do
it with a minimal amount of bureaucracy
if you can do you also have advice maybe
as
during this last round for a starter
pissed artist artists were watching us
and would like is there one thing that
you would like to leave them as a tip
you can think about it another second if
you like maybe on the same subject these
big immigrants that you can get is
really great especially for a company
like ask this very orangey heavy and
need a lot of money to reach the market
and but they're really hard like
administratively and like everyone I
know that got amused a consultant that
like specifically focus on writing yeah
and it takes like 10% of the grant which
feels like waste and a suggestion a
harvest that maybe you could use because
like Dan said I'm part of climate kick
it's a great program it's an accelerated
program for clean tech startups within
the EU and I would say maybe it's more
of a community and network rather than a
program and because you get to know not
only like I have a Swedish business
coach but I also get to know like the
contact point in Norway and then
American Spain very good and I mean
we're in the program for like one a half
year so this business coaches know it's
very well and they know where I am
startups very well and like how our
go-to-market strategy so maybe it would
be easier to channel some of the money
like in the age proclaimed cake or in
energy or I mean program that you're
already have in place that is really
good and helping a lot of their startups
we get some money but it's very small
compared to the big runs a few managed
answer both my questions with one answer
you propose to the vice-president you
gave an advice to start the best water
watching us and what they can do I'm
telling you the future is millennial
[Music]
yeah I have let's say few money a few
more ideas regarding reality
I'll try I'll try more and more often
now it will be chance to have
second live of the batteries and reality
because first first generation of the
cars will actually will be old five
seven some of those ten years old so
more and more often we will have an
issue with the recycling of the
batteries and we all I mean order there
is a there is a clear let's say
political strategy to go for a second
light of the batteries and to use it for
a more grid stability this is this is
very nice idea and we we are very happy
that this is here but on the other hand
that's not the case for the regulation I
mean the regulation is not prepared for
somebody who will be however and not
even on the other hand it should be even
like supported for such a behavior that
you are putting something on a grid and
I mean creation kind of stability video
or let's say battery even if you are in
the premiere or sometimes this storage
system whatsoever so this kind of
graduation is completely unfortunately
still missing okay very good vice
president we put you in a difficult
position with you so much ideas and
information as you from the studio from
the your LinkedIn community so now maybe
some final word from you on what you
think that how will this feed you for
your next two days when you're going to
the forum do you feel like you are good
no yeah I can see that and you better
quickly I'm definitely better equipped
for tomorrow's discussion and maybe I
will start from that from that from the
last suggestion because I think I have a
good news for for you I that if it comes
to the storing of energy we are just
finalizing meaning that we just need to
get approval from the European
Parliament and the Member State the
agreement on the new electricity market
design and and and I often say that what
we proposed there is the deepest
transformation of our energy system
since they've been built in Europe 150
years ago and and put on fossil bases
because what we are proposing there is
digitization of the grades it's a
demand-side management it's a reward for
ability to store the energy and in this
case we feel that
mobility and batteries are such a
crucial next big thing because with all
that capacity of batteries which you'll
need in Europe as because we expected by
2025 it would be already the market of
250 billion euros annually so we
definitely want to use that the capacity
of storing the energy of those batteries
for balancing our electricity grids and
cover for that in terminal intermittency
of renewables like solar and wind so
it's it's been that it will be done I'm
sure that the next decade will start
under the new management new framework
and new electricity market design which
would support these these new
technologies of course for that we need
the standardization of batteries as well
we need to weigh batteries not only the
batteries which can take the energy but
also the batteries which can sell it
back to the grid and I personally like
the idea that if you have electric car
that we can actually earn you some money
because they can they can sell the
energy back into the transmission system
when when the energy is very expensive
when when the car is idling in in the
garage for example and I totally take
take the point from from a mine from
Professor and simplification of our
grounds I get it a lot and I'm very
often as a as a as a you Commissioner
sorry to hear that
that the people prefer to go to the bank
than to apply for you grants because I
simply - administratively but under some
and complicated and I agree with Emma
that if we have I mean the new budget
money they should go for the project
support not for consultants who can
prepare this project so we are trying to
simplify we are in the midst of
preparation of the next seven years
budget we want possible when it member
state would work with us to double the
money for research and innovation and to
have more flexible financial instruments
which would be easier to administer and
which also would be in such a mode that
they could be blended with other
investments coming from national or or
or private private sector but what I
think we would need now and in the
future
is something what we have set up for our
mayor's it's Advisory hub for innovators
for start-up community that would have a
number you would have an email address
but you can get an advice I have such a
project what is the best address he who
can give me the advice what grants what
program what investment tool would be
the best for promoting my idea so we
would not lose the time with consultants
or going through the different programs
we have in a you to find the right one
for you
so that's something what you definitely
have to pick up and I hope that we can
really start work on it because I know
that my colleague Carlos is responsible
for this 80 billion of horizon 2020 gets
the same feedback as I get from the
innovation communities in in Europe and
I think it would definitely help us with
creating more type of business angel
investment this is what I really feel we
are missing and therefore we are losing
a lot of innovators to Silicon Valley
and or or to China because there it's
easier to get funding for for the for
the good new ideas and and from other
suggestions which been made I very much
like the idea of these green branding
and an early on because this is
something where Europe is different from
the from the from the rest of the world
and I think that should be that should
be our European brand and if something
coming from Europe its high-tech it's
clean tech its green its sustainable and
it's of high quality and I think this is
what we should try to incorporate in in
all our products be the cars with the
batteries be the data centers because
this is what the people in Europe but
I'm sure increasingly across the globe
would would appreciate more and more and
then I have some more ideas here which I
will say for the community of investors
in industrial is tomorrow so really
thank you very much for the
contributions and also to our colleagues
on the LinkedIn community because I saw
that it keeps they're coming to my watch
I mean I saw there was quite the quality
traffic with a good idea vibrating the
hand of the vice president you're doing
a good job on that note I'd like to
thank you vice president for taking the
time for hosting us on your LinkedIn
page I'd like to thank the three of you
Damien MIUI for joining us here today
and I'd like to take two Thank You
viewers on YouTube on LinkedIn for
taking the time for taking part in this
fascinating discussion I think we just
created LinkedIn live together
for the first time from us here in
Brussels thank you and see you next time
you